منذ قليل دخلت قافله انسانيه الى معبر باب
الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا هذه القافله تتضمن
سته شاحنات محمله بمواد انسانيه ومواد
استجابه طارئه ولكن القائمين على اداره
معظر باب الهوى الحدودي قالوا للجزيره ان
هذه القافله ليس لها علاقه بالاستجابه
الطارئه للمتضررين من الزلزال الذي ضرب
شمال غرب سوريا وكان من المفترض ان تدخل
هذه القافله الى داخل السوري منذ ايام اي
قبل حدوث الزلزال اداره معبر باب الهوى
الحدودي مع تركيا قالت للجزيره انه بعد
مضيء اكثر من ثمانين ساعه على الزلزال
الذي ضرب المنطقه لم يصل اي مساعدات
انسانيه او استجابه طارئه للمتضررين جراء
الزلزال سواء كان من المنظمات محليه او
حتى ان كان من منظمات اقليميه او دوليه
على الرغم من المناشدات التي اطلقها
القائمون العمل الانساني هنا في شمال غرب
سوريا بضروره الاستجابه الطارئه لالاف
العائلات التي تبيت بالعراء منذ ايام وسط
الظروف انسانيه صعبه وانخفاض في درجات
الحراره ولكن دون استجابه حتى تاريخ اعداد
هذا التقرير ادم ابو حسام الجزيره
معبر باب الهواء الحدودي مع تركيا